[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
nah i'm joking i'm joking with you guys
right now i'm alone
i'm sure the other two will be showing
up here momentarily
uh what's going on guys you know and
plus i went a little i went live a
little a little early
as you guys could see i got this little
line here that's just because it's two
scenes stacked on top of each other but
i like the way it looks
so so so ada kept it going
see look at that man i'm splitting
myself up how many podcasts can you guys
say
yo that's crazy that's crazy
that's that's intense
hold up
hold up let's let let's let's go a
little bit further
to infinity and beyond
look at that man look at that man this
is how i'm going to talk to the other
ones show up man this is how i'm going
to talk to the other one show up
this is
this is the
what's all i'm looking for
it's the punishment of myself
you don't get this nowhere else you
don't man look how i'm talking right now
look my head's cut off
man look at that man what's going on
guys man what's going on you know
waiting for the other people to show up
dirk told me he'd be a little late uh so
but you know i'm sure he'll get here
momentarily
man like
i gotta turn
this up a little bit
yeah right there's fine
well what's going on guys
what is going on i'll be there in a few
minutes looking man people being late
people being late
how you guys feel about these
these laters
see i got i got to speak
in secondaries and stuff because they
late
what game was for me next okay here
here's the thing about the streaming
thing
all right so i do have a gaming addict
youtube channel
um
thinking about turning it into a
streaming channel because i'm just look
i love
making videos but i do feel like i'm
fatigued on it and i do enjoy
i do enjoy streaming i do enjoy
streaming so
i personally feel like i need to do what
i enjoy doing
that's just me though
hold up hold up
this is
this is how i am now
yo this is crazy i'm getting way too
much entertainment out of this
i blame you guys i blame you guys see
see if everyone would have showed up on
time i wouldn't be
without a neck right now my neck is gone
it is officially
gone
and
big cloud
and dirt should feel ashamed of
themselves
because
they are responsible
for the neck being kept took care of
you know i mean i could go a little
further
we could just do a podcast like this
you guys could see my eyes
you guys can see my eyes
my eyes
it's how you guys do it
how you guys do it
i see you
what you doing
all right i'll stop now i'll stop now
i'll stop
i understand i'm being too much
i am being too much i get it
uh you know
so you know we'll have a little bit of a
chat man stay on topic what's the topic
what was we talking about in the topic a
second ago what was we talking about
because uh clearly
i don't know man i don't know
what was we talking about what do you
guys think the topic is
you know wha what's out of all the stuff
that we're going to talk about today on
the attic show what's the one that
really entices you guys the most man we
got a bunch of stuff you guys want to
see
my topic list you guys want to see it
i feel like you guys want to see it
let's let's look at it let's look at it
hold up
you know i'm going to do this
that i'm a i'm a screen capture
this one let's turn it to
the sticky note bam
dirk griggity is here
so we'll go ahead and
hold up hold up dart greggy will will be
here momentarily guys
i'm sure he he's busy
are you talking dirt
uh what's up yeah i can hear you dirt so
i don't know if you guys could see this
you know because we're waiting for big
cloud
somehow dirt griggity told me he was
gonna be late uh big cloud is late late
like there was no
there's no warning he's just late
okay this is the wrong one this is the
wrong one
uh
i want to show them
is is it just not gonna show up okay
let's just do this one
yeah the this is the topics guys
this is the topic
oh
see i got sticky notes on
my other screen
and it signifies
like all the important stuff like
because i game on my middle screen which
i probably need to upgrade it eventually
when you when your boy gets a little bit
of a moolah but it's okay so i don't
know if you guys can see that
uh because it's it's pretty
all right so there it is man there it is
we got cortor delay
we don't even know what you're looking
at i don't even know what i'm looking at
sometimes man i don't even know what i'm
looking at
uh first off what's going on dirk
what do the the two man shall we wait
for the third person to be late
yeah i can hear you fine
what you doing man
dirt dirt low-key uh streaming from the
inside of a jail cell he just don't want
to see
he was i need that laptop
i need that laptop that's what they say
i had you muted there for a second
that's what i need that laptop so i
could so i could stream for the imagine
like you coming in there like like you
you get like um a string and a hook and
you're trying to like hook the laptop
that's on the on the desk and then when
you get it they just walk in and they
just see you sitting there streaming
talking about xbox and [ __ ]
that's right xbox
hey can y'all hear me now
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure they can hear
you now okay you know what's funny man
what's funny
is what's been going on on uh we'll go
ahead and get rid of this actually like
that i might try to do something unique
with that
uh what's been going on is all this
capping going on on twitter man like you
know we we we we got some stuff for you
guys because like i said i do have
some stuff we're going to talk about you
guys know it
we we do
generally stay away from you know we we
might joke a little bit about the
the
the nonsense that happens on uh on
youtube on twitter but you know
sometimes we got to bring it up
sometimes sometimes we got to it it's
just we gotta bring it up uh so yeah
they can hear you now uh so we're gonna
go ahead and move on well we will
bitcloud will be here when bitcloud
decides to be here
uh you know he he's a busy dude man he's
a busy dude
let me go ahead and and get and prepare
for him showing up
all right there we go
so you know what they're gonna see two
of us that's what they gonna see
they're gonna see two of us because i
demand it
you know i i don't i don't need
a third and fourth person
look at that dirt like we got enough we
got enough we got enough personality
between the two of us that we could
split ourselves let's go
look at this man
that's how things go hold up hold up
hold up i got i got to flip it i know
completely
being reckless today but it's okay
no i can't i was trying to flip it
all right so you know let let's talk a
little bit about the side stuff while we
wait for big cloud to get up in here
uh so i saw you going at it with some
people of the xbox revenue i saw you
going out of people man so why don't you
explain
your uh justifications for uh going out
with some of the playstation uh
brethren on on twitter what's going on
man i i saw you going through it this
morning
let me tell you this first um
when it comes to twitter
i never
tag ponies or go after them
initially
they always come after me if there are
some
news that they think is bad they will dm
me or they will tag me or they will come
after me
so that's what happened yesterday with
the uh you know like the
the xbox earning reports you know those
guys just automatically you know saw
things in the negative and they oh
so this guy tags me and
oh look dirk are you gonna do a video
about this
i'm like bro it was still you know their
best fiscal year
no then it came through to a whole thing
then some more playstation fanboys
joined in on me then the the
conversation turned from that to somehow
um the road the the future because you
know they have xbox has no games 2022 so
that's their go-to right now xbox has
gone games 20 32. i'll say okay fine
and
2023 when
when we're getting probably hellblade in
the holiday hopefully i don't know we
getting a
field
we get a lot of different stuff like
i just like here's the thing i'm not
saying that this year isn't bad this
year is pretty bad for an xbox gamer if
you if you enjoy nothing but first party
that's the only thing you play in this
world it's not gonna be a good year for
you but the same people that are coming
at us man the same people loading the
rifles
you know
first off they come at me
like they can keep up with that i
am a fully automatic weapon and you guys
are muskets all right it takes you
months to load up your your shots and
i'm sitting here i've already wasted
half of the room okay
like no you guys can't mess with me all
right that that's just how it is you
guys take two minutes to shoot your shot
and you miss it you gotta reload again
and it takes you three months to reload
that shot like lay off of me man none of
you can handle this
talk that stuff
uh yeah but that's what happened then
like i said the conversation changed too
um
excuse me
games and
like you said i mentioned well the road
map for xbox looks great well
playstation has a great road map so i
said yeah you know they got spiderman
and wolverine and what else he's like oh
what they got square enix and i said
does
like the sony own them yet no so
technically that's not first party well
for spoken and i said listen man you
guys got to stop changing the narratives
bro if you want to say no first party
like no xbox first party for 2022 we can
do that but if you xbox does technically
have some exclusives this year that's
not first party so you can't do that so
it became a whole thing and then i just
got tired of it and you know because
they those guys never shut up so
yeah that's what was happening man i
have noticed that when it comes to
stuff like that look
i penement
i'm not looking forward to it because
it's not the type of game that i want
from obsidian
but it doesn't take away for the fact
it's made by joshua he's a very talented
individual it's going to be a good game
most likely yeah and for the most part
obsidian don't miss like you know i i
have a good track record of hitting on
target they have a very good track
record of hitting on target
and it's just like you know let me get
this two dollar super chat real quick
two dollar super chat from phantom
kraken dirt is always late well dirk
told me he was gonna be late okay yeah
joey oh look who it is man look who it
is
took forever to be showing up
there we go
see now i got to fix everything
no you don't messed everything up i mean
you messed everything up i don't know i
don't know
look i'm going to make you the smallest
one here too just because you was late
yeah it all right so that that should be
good all right we we got we got our we
got a the other person here now so
now we are full panel and you know we
we're gonna have a pretty good show man
welcome to the attic show
where we talk about the past
present future gaming i got my
at this point my co-host was to be dirt
griggity wha wha what's going on dirk
man uh he's coming straight
from whatever prison is near your dirt
whatever prison's near you
you mean you don't need a brother i was
on mule [ __ ] my wife was up there
vacuuming like what the hell uh what's
up y'all how y'all doing man
doing pretty good man then we got big
cloud gaming you know he he he's going
to be joining us for a little bit yeah
the addict and dirt show uh no we got
big clouds here man xbox you got big
cloud is here it's not just i get it
like you know me me and dirk are most
likely always going to be throwing big
clouds face in the dirt because he's the
playstation fan but it is dirt big clock
can hold his own i i could assure you
the clown could definitely hold us on i
mean we got games which you got you know
i want to get in come on
man
what's going on uh sorry for me being
late uh
yeah i was just talking to uh adam
sessler
uh
with um jaffy so sorry about that
all right oh sorry okay so
we
i thought he was going to say more i'm
sitting here like oh no i don't know all
right you right now so we're gaming.net
we in the building what's going on
we got a good show for you guys today
we're going to talk about uh the couture
delay i'm sure i'm sure dirk is going to
love that one we're going to talk about
the halo forge leaks i don't know if you
guys have seen those leaks
we're also going to talk about the
verizon partnership that's kind of
interesting that i saw
and we got a little bit of small topics
i got to talk about xbox revenue which
you know me and dirk kind of uh briefly
went over we didn't really go over it
was just talking about how uh how dirt
is uh you know super dragon fisting some
people on twitter over it uh we got a
gta 6 news uh apparently there's
probably going to be a female lead on
that and then we got sony might be
buying square enix and i feel like i got
three attic shows with that title uh but
we gonna have a fourth man we gonna have
a fourth so you know i will go ahead you
know out of everything i said man bit
what do you want to talk about first wha
what's something that interests you
i mean there's so many things to talk
about i guess
i would go with the uh gta news that's
the the gta news for all you guys know
gta 5
is switched between three characters
michael
trevor trevor and
franklin franklin actually i actually
liked franklin the most i thought he was
the yeah most went out character i
actually think that it goes like
franklin
trevor and michael for some reason i
didn't like michael i don't know why um
i liked all of all three man they were
good no but it's not that i might maybe
saying i didn't like him is too much i
felt like like in the least out of all
the characters
he offered the least compared to
everyone uh so he was trying to be
hollywood that's what he was trying to
be he was really trying
so out of all that going on we actually
do have some news coming out of rockstar
i felt like it's been 10 years since
we've heard anything about gta 6. it
hasn't straight come from rockstar but
there's a lot of speculation and good
leaks going on by reputable people that
it looks like they're going to do
something similar with that but one of
those characters is going to be a female
like i think a latino lead and i want to
get you guys because here here's my
thing i don't understand like i see
people getting upset over this and i'm
like
why do you care if you could play as a
woman as one of their perspectives like
like if anything
like i actually feel like that actually
might that that might actually help a
gta story to have like a a female
perspective in the game badass that'd be
nice i don't think uh that's the issue
though honestly it's not really the
female
lead uh the issue for it is because i
don't know if you read the report from
jason schreier um basically the team is
saying that they're trying to get away
from reality like like they're trying to
get away from like the black lives
matter type of stuff they're trying to
get away from the george floyd you know
incident and so they're talking about
toning it down even staying away from
certain jokes that they made prior prior
in gta 5 like you guys remember when
they released gta 5 on the ps5 and
whatnot they remove the transphobic
jokes so they're removing they don't
want to go down those roads where that
might instigate or or
piss people off that are you know i mean
like sensitive on those particular
topics that's why a lot of people are
upset because they're like um why are we
sending like why are we you know
toning down a game that's known to go
over the top i mean i get it i
absolutely absolutely get it like you
know
it's
you know it's understandable nobody
wants to see a game especially a game
like gta which is known for
being like over the top they don't want
to see that get toned down and when you
add in like a female character as well i
mean the female character i actually
thought i was open to it because you
know bonnie and clyde that's what
they're talking about okay that's cool
you know two bank robbers you might be
able to tell us something crazy but now
people are questioning you know how this
female character go look is she gonna
have a crazy is she gonna look like you
know a very beautiful woman type of
thing or is she gonna be toned down and
look rough kind of like tests or
something like that you know everybody's
asked a question about it i'm like yeah
i'll wait till i see the finished
product before i pass judgment on how
she will do but as far as like the fear
and like how people are going about it i
understand i'm with them 110
i don't want to see this game take no
like like i don't want to see a gta of
all games walk on eggshells to not piss
people off because that's how the
franchise became popular that's what the
franchise was known for nobody was
complaining back in san andreas remember
that um from that dirt with san andreas
dave was like dawg we didn't get
offended we like that's it that's that's
hey this is this is real
yeah it was real listen so that's what
i'm saying like they don't want to they
don't want to do that and now if you
think about it too
because they're also they also said in a
report that they don't see women as
sexual objects like they collectively
said this in the thing like we don't see
women as sexual objects so i know a lot
of people like to do the whole thing
would they be scouting for prostitutes
in the game i have a feeling they're
going to tone that down as well you're
not going to be seeing as many
prostitutes patrolling the city if not
they'll probably be in like the worst
parts of the city but i don't think
they'll have it they even reflect their
real gas prices in the game as well like
it's it's wow
so
the last thing i want to see too though
is the dialogue being like this like i
don't know if y'all saw the trailer for
that texas chainsaw massacre remake
thing that was on netflix no look at the
channel yeah i said well the dude was
like the dude has a chainsaw you know
he's walking up to him right on the bus
and dude pulls out his cell phone takes
a picture of him like he's live on
facebook he's like if you say if you get
if you make if you take one more step
closer you're cancelled buddy i don't
want to see stuff like that and you did
when they like hey you're gonna be
canceled you come near me i don't see
that so
yeah that's right yeah that's where i'm
at with those things
yeah man this um
i love gta 5 i think it's like a
masterpiece i really do like it's
a very well done game um as far as this
one i did hear even like before this
league that
the two protagonists are twins male and
female twins i don't know how true that
will be but i guess we'll see um
you know i i agree with everything big
cloud just said the only unfortunate
part about everything you just said i
wholeheartedly believe
and it's just unfortunately man we're in
a time where
everybody wants to be offended
yeah during the sins like during the
early 2000s like the san andreas time i
always think about like you arrested the
family like the attitude era some of
that stuff that happened back then
man they wouldn't they wouldn't allow
some of that stuff now so it was like
them tony excuse me them toning gta 6
down
i don't want that
but i'm not surprised if it happens
just because in today's time it's just
like that man i remember
people went back and found some stuff
that kevin hart said 18 years ago like
eight nine years ago ten years ago and
you know say hey man do you remember you
said this word on twitter and like what
so it's just like where it is in a
different time man um so i really think
all of that is possible everything you
said is possible um but i hope that's
not the case because i want gta as we
know gta
you know some some some chicks walking
around the streets
like you're going in the alley having
fun
doing all that stuff but yeah it's
definitely possible man but i'm looking
forward to the game especially for it to
be in vice city aka miami
i love it man i love it
yeah i mean he here goes with me is i do
personally feel like
this is a gta online scenario i feel
like they made a lot of money off gta
online and the only thing that they felt
like could have made that more money is
if it was more acceptable socially
uh so i think that they might go away
from a lot of their extra extra stuff
they love doing in favor of
doing more of a what's wrong i'm looking
for
ongoing service thing because because
they um did say that in the report ign
even covered it they said that um
they are regularly going to be dropping
content on the game when it drops or
whatnot so
this can be missions i'm guessing or
maybe heist because i'm guessing the
whole theme of this is gonna be robbing
right bank bank i so i can see heist
dropping the only thing i don't the only
thing i don't want to see in this game i
don't want to see us having to pay
extra for story related missions you
know i'm saying i don't want to see that
if it's online based okay cool that
makes sense you know you just keep
feeding though you know you keep feeding
those who want the the heist and want to
make money online that's fun that's fine
i don't think anybody would complain
about that but
it's just a single player portion and as
far as like um how you play this game
too because a lot of people like oh i
don't want to play as just a female well
more likely you're going to play as a
guy anyway in the studio because um it's
going to be like gta 5 controls where
you switch in between so they're going
to have separate missions for each if
that makes sense and you'll find out
more about the more context so it's
it's just one of those situations again
a lot of people are upset about stuff i
just think we need to wait to see it
before we
legit
jump
the bridge
i think the biggest reason
that people are upset with this is
because we're seeing it affect every
media we love the movie industry
uh even to some degree so uh the comedy
industry is pretty much a show of what
it used to be we're seeing it and uh the
music industry people aren't afraid to
make the kind of music they made 10
years ago and it's just like looking
crazy and i think people always saw
gta
is that dev like rockstar is that divine
we ain't ever gonna do anything to sell
out things like we always gonna be true
to our core and now that we're seeing
something like this we see okay even
people like rockstar are
okay
susceptible to being attacked by the uh
the twitterverse because that's what i
consider it's the twitterverse man it's
pretty much like equivalent
to having
like
a like a constant
spirit bomb that people are trying to
get that power at all times and
it's just like you know i mean yeah what
you're saying is true though look at
what they did with the san andreas or
the trilogy remastered thing remember
from how they could have really pushed
that and made it look really really
detailed and make all the women
everything look good they didn't bother
to do that because again this goes back
to that mentality in the studio of not
seeing and or not viewing women as
objects sexual harassment they don't
they don't care man so
and my thing is like i don't mind
i don't mind
having
a little of each like uh you know people
for some reason i people think
that women either
you got
outlets that make you think women
don't you know have a good sex appeal
they don't appreciate they don't they
it's like everyone wants you to think
one of the others either all chicks
dress crazy
or chicks don't dress like that at all
and it's just like it's in the middle
there's people there's women out there
that are busty it's just how it is like
and it's just like well we got to have a
good middle ground to where it's like
we're not but like we need to portray
women not women that like the developers
want to portray if that makes sense like
it's just like if women in general there
is all types of people out there you
know and i think that's the biggest
issue is you know
we've went
to such this right side that now you
have the women that aren't represented
anymore in the games because we have
this new aspect of what a woman should
like they're like look like
i i respect the way they're dressing the
way that they present themselves but now
i'm not being presented
and it's just like look man
like we could do everything man i could
assure you we could do everything yeah
but
it's just people i don't even like using
the work woke i don't think that's like
an accurate thing
it isn't but at the same time that's
kind of what these dudes are like
whatever it is like whatever it's not
like a generic white male they could say
they legit just go off the deep end like
look at saints row you guys remember the
saints for everybody's gone
because you saw the woman i'm like dude
it's the female is optional you can
create your own character right yeah i
mean
what are we what are we doing here this
is not just something that's forced this
is on you you look stupid and dude's
like no it's vocal they're forcing it
and what's funny the same thing is i see
uh lord metro it said double standards i
don't even think it's double standards
because the the
most okay there are men out there that
saying stuff like this but for the most
part it's women wanting to de-sexualize
women like it's not really men like i
can assure you men don't want women
desexual
it's not it's it's women like
a certain set of women have conceived in
their mindset that every woman has to
dress and look just like them or
they're you know they're being too much
there's like all types of different
standards that people have going in i
think it's crazy it's just like look
like you know that that's like
equivalent to me not wanting people to
you know
make
people with beards it's like look we got
to make everyone bald clean shaved
that that's that's the ideal and if you
look at it like a lot of people are that
way bald and clean shaved like just
because the vast majority do something
and let's keep in mind like the women
that that want the industry pushed this
way they're not the majority like
there's way more average women out there
that that do what they want to and they
they don't see
uh you know and i don't like getting
political but it's it's just it's
what it is
as a game it's not real it's just like a
fantasy and that's kind of how rockstar
always looked at it it's just a fantasy
of real like i said fantasy
interpretation of reality you know i
mean it was that it had that frat boy
mindset where you know you have
beautiful women you got dudes trying to
be superstars you got psychos parole in
the streets you got crackheads you got
everything dopings you have everything
everywhere happening all at once and it
just puts you
at the helm of this and guess what you
have freedom jerome that's pretty much
what made gta what it was and you have
relatable and memorable characters
absolutely and you know what i mean and
when you step away from nets and when
you start toning down like they're what
they're talking about
that's where you're going to start
messing with the the essence it's
the essence people get this you can
speak for everyone like and what's funny
is like they want oh tomb raider you
know she's too busy okay maybe she has
showed a little too cleavage but guess
what that's always been her mo like she
doesn't do it intentionally on the
screen or anything but it's just like
like you look at something like tomb
raider like the newest tomb raiders they
make those are good games
and what's funny is those games was able
to take advantage of the fact that they
didn't need to be
out in the ocean yeah but but then you
look at something like that
you look something like bayonetta where
that is her persona that's her character
right both can exist and still do fine
but the problem is is one one set of
people think that the left one needs to
exist and another set of people think
the right ones exist when it's just like
look like i think the biggest issue we
have right now in this in the society is
no one wants to be wrong and everyone
wants to convert other people's opinions
to their own and if it isn't that way
then they call it sexist
uh all types of stuff you know it's a
line of stuff like i saw um yeah people
was upset over
them switching
uh
uh wesker's character to black in the tv
show and i watched the show and it was
good and i can assure you
that show had plenty of things wrong but
it wasn't him being wesker
that was actually one of the best things
about the show like
it's just like but i can't understand
coming from a person that that has been
watching these characters develop love
the west persona you know i can
understand why people are like yo but
he's not black
but see we got to do a better job at
understanding what is what and what is
just because you have an opinion on
something doesn't make you a racist it's
like unless you have alternative motives
why you don't want him to be black has
nothing to do with his character you
just don't want a black you don't want a
black person on the screen then you're
racist
but and i feel like we have a bad thing
of just like labeling everything
everything
and it's just like as a society we need
to be better on that
no you know
i want you to be part of the heat mob
let's put it like that exactly but adam
and you said something um because i
think you mentioned this on wbg a couple
weeks ago
like you just said people want
other people to agree with their opinion
they want you to feel how they feel
and i mean if you look at
fandom like not just this council war
that we do
sports man i'm talking about sports i've
seen heated debates
joy no lebron who's the greatest and
it's like
it's at a point where
you just like man you know i just want
to hold my opinion to myself especially
on social media because if you say one
thing
one side of people will say oh you're
being this way you're you're you're
you're a bot you're you're not being
fair if you say something else you know
it's just like
you're absolutely right man that's the
point that's the time we're living in
and this didn't just start
but social media has enhanced it right
let me address seth god's plea this
still sounded like a video game podcast
look
i'm gonna have to uh respectfully
disagree with you on this like social
aspects do affect video games like we're
literally talking about gta
the the this guy started the king
of i'ma do what i want and if it's bad
or good publicity that's on you
bending to the will of
social media like that if if that's not
oh he said i'm joking dude okay look
look look look at that the reason i had
to pick on you is because i've been on
iop long enough when i see a post like
that i feel like it's real because
people are like that you can ask both
people here they both post their own
shows dudes immediately go this isn't
what this about that's not that's not
situation it's like bro it is like
this is rockstar rockstar is known for
pushing the envelope and not caring
about any repercussions or caring about
how you feel they took some of them they
made some of the most boldest
steps
in video games it's it's equivalent to
south park
not wanting to do stuff because it might
it's against it's against the grain like
i will never i will never forget when i
played the second south park the
difficulties what skin color you have
that is that is like the craziest stuff
ever and when you look at some of these
like like and it was oh and what's funny
is it wasn't anything to do with the
combat like it was social aspects
and just like look like that
i forgot about that i love that though
it's like you haven't heard it because
you're black and i was like dude that's
that's that's funny just like he was
talking about your religious your
religious beliefs in the first one i
remember he said if you're a jew
you uh have like the best loadout but
it's like you feel like you're proud by
the first carbon the first time i played
as a warrior and the second time i
played as a jew and you there's crazy
attacks you could use as a
jewish on wow so you know that's pretty
much all we got anyone got anything more
on the gta thing because it's like i
don't feel like there's a lot to talk
about you know we got to see exactly
what happens we got to see yeah you know
uh they could be just saying this there
could have been
internal conflict
behind closed doors of them fighting and
you know maybe some of the higher ups
are going out i don't know uh we need
more information about that we need we
definitely needed another
title
if the characters we play yes like you
guys remember the internet cafe for gta
4 we had to do flight today absolutely
yeah i remember that they bring that
back and like the only way to date women
in this game is to go on only fans and
all these sites like that but they're if
they're equivalent i'm gonna laugh
that's gonna be funny but at the same
time that's gonna piss people off i'm
like dude i don't wanna i don't wanna
replicate what's going on
i'm excited for the game man yeah it's
it's gonna be a dope game man
and also um too
this might lead a little bit more
credits
to red dead
three i know you remember the report
murder report for red dead three have
been saying that sadie aller was gonna
be like the main protagonist really yeah
it was like going around like they were
looking to push a lead protagonist so it
might be sadie adler returning for part
three and um you just play as john's son
and yeah the the final uh nail so yeah
okay
that'll be out in 20
20 uh like twenty
someone's like 20 29 20 30. you know
i've been huh yeah
i'm gonna be older yeah
and one thing i want to bring up to you
know before we're about to go to the
next top we're gonna talk about sony you
know we love talking about sony but um
uh i do want to point out that i am
going to be doing more stuff with the
attic show as you guys can see i have
like a scrolling going on with the text
i don't don't expect that weekly i'm
just messing around with what i could do
on the show second off you know i kind
of want to make this you know kind of
like the emotes from iop but i want to
do it more i want to really be extra
with the emotes like i i want to push a
button on my steam deck and like it's
like a fully animated
emote that's coming throughout the
screen you know what i'm saying so we'll
see what happens on there i am um
working with uh the lords on new
merchandise i might bring in some uh
attic uh attic show merchandise as well
but you know once i lock in a permanent
set of members which i think this is a
good group uh you know hustle got a new
job so i don't think he's coming back he
he's he's you know breaking in the new
job
uh shout out to him so you know once i
validate
the people that are because people don't
realize how hard it is to host anything
like at any time
they think it's easier but
you could lose your whole damn staff
like
and you like like what's funny is like
when hustle told me he he didn't know if
he would be able to do the show anymore
because of stuff i was thinking
damn i have to do this by myself
and you know i could do single podcasts
if i if if i had to but they're not fun
i like bouncing off the people but you
know there are going to be changes
coming to the attic show
you know definitely put in the comment
section what kind of changes you guys
would like to see i'm probably not going
to listen to none of you but i'm was i'm
willing to what i'm going to read the
comments so i'm willing to read the
comments i'll give you that much so
let's talk about sony and square enix
man we have been hearing for the longest
time that sony might buy square enix
uh and now it's looking like there
actually might
be some remnants of truth behind this
for those who don't know they actually
interviewed the individual over there i
think it was martial games or whatever
that company's called uh he was talking
and he pretty much insinuated that he
heard that they might be interested in
buying sony i mean square enix so
first thing i want to do is i want to
ask dirk griggity are you shocked
because i'm not
no not at all and i think it makes sense
i'm not shocked at all especially after
the recent moves that square enix has
made
uh think of i mean hell look at all of
the
exclusivity that sony has with screening
so i know i'm not surprised at all and
like i said i think it makes a lot of
sense to be honest with you
yeah i feel like when it comes to this
it just
it's the natural progression of what
we're seeing going on uh you know i'm
pretty sure you if you ask big cloud
it makes sense if this happens a bit
cloud would you be surprised
nope i've been tossing up either square
enix or capcom for the longest time
capcom makes a hell of a lot of sense as
well with sony really trying to get into
esports and buying evo and whatnot so
i mean i could see that being one of
their poster boys for capcom to be on
there especially for street fighter them
having that as a heavy fighter and
pushing that and also who knows that
might lead to something with bandai
namco with tekken i do think sony really
wants to get into the competitive gaming
side especially with i don't know if
i've been seeing their official uh
youtube page but they'd be posting like
little esports like plays like like
mortal kombat stuff like that on there
uh live streams
i do think they really see a future in
that there was even a patent going
around about how you can bet on your
favorite streamer who's fighting
and you know do that type of thing like
a betting system so they they are going
towards that so
yeah
uh what would you
what is your overall opinion on the
thing uh dirt do you do you think it's
something that they need or do you think
this is just icing on the cake i'm kind
of curious to hear both guys opinion on
that uh let's go ahead and get this two
dollar super chat from lloyd metro sony
and square enix exchanging rings long
ago exchange rings long ago i don't know
i don't know if i would agree with that
but i do uh
good friends they they they they they
they've been f buddies for a long time
now they're putting out
yeah pretty much yeah i don't know if
you saw the other one
um from phantom cracking gta should be
like south park and not give a damn he
said that a little while back
oh is it super [ __ ] oh yeah well yeah
and i agree with them i really really
should grow yeah i agree with them there
i mean but again um you know how people
are they find ways to blame video games
for
everything crazy people in in society
and that has nothing to do with video
games that's literally people who are
sick i remember
reading an article it was a while ago
but do kill this mom and then the dude
when he got the little kid like he got
he killed his mom he shot her then he
tried to molest his mother with the
corpse of his mother and then um
when they arrested him what not he said
yeah i thought i can press the reset
button on my console and she would come
back i'm like
that's mentally understanding and then
do a video uh-huh
so i was like that makes no sense like
but dudes are
fine ways to do that
yeah that's wow um
hey addict so
what did you say right before the super
chats like the question you asked me i
kind of forgot
i i was just asking you do you think
it's something necessary that scoring
enix uh that would be need to be bought
and you know i feel like
it's one of those things where
sony
doesn't necessarily need them
but i do feel like they realize
with microsoft buying up studios there
isn't a possibility one time they might
go ahead and buy them
uh and you know obviously we don't think
that there's a chance that microsoft can
buy square enix but you never know you
never know what's gonna happen in the
future you never know if if microsoft
pops up was like i got a deal for you
like i'm gonna drop 20 bees on you
like sign those contracts you mine now
and then you know if we don't know what
happens after that for all you know in
the words of king david they then at
that point it's like you ain't for the
streets no more you mine we right no i'm
for the streets you you're from my
library but i'ma still step out and do
what i want
all right so you know what
i'm sorry no
that's all i just want to know uh you
know what your thoughts
yeah i think um
i think what sony is doing i don't think
they need square enix
i don't i just think they want to
make sure final fantasy
doesn't leave their platform in the
future let me explain of course they
have deals and everything like that but
in today's gaming industry as we've seen
xbox is buying the publishers like you
just said xbox is behind the publishers
embracer we got 10 cent
if if
square enix is up for sale
sony like look you know look we don't
want anybody else to pick you guys up we
will get you guys and we heard how they
uh you know sold off the western
developers
you know just so make sure like just to
make sure that playstation is getting
them
maybe sony didn't want crystal dynamics
or idols montreal or whatever
it just makes a lot of sense man and i
just don't think that you know like
everybody uh in the chat here's the
actual article sorry i found it oh yes
for the article you guys want to see it
that it's it's legit that's what
happened that's crazy
um but i just think it's like you never
know
you know like you think about
even going back in the days with
insomniac they always did games with
sony until they didn't they did a couple
multiflash and they made an xbox
exclusive so sony said you know what you
never know
these teams they're like they're
mercenaries but at the same time we need
to pick these guys up and that's what
they did and now they're one of sony's
best developers so i just believe
sony really loves the um final fantasy
franchise they want it up under them and
i mean
it is right now uh as a you know
second party or timed exclusive i don't
think it's time exclusive anymore bro
it's just they wanted to make official
that's all you said like there were
friends they were partners now they're
just making it they're going to make it
official
it's like i said not to mention like we
don't know
what eventually happens to
imagine a world
where so we're we wake up
and we see on twitter
microsoft bought square enix like and i
don't it's like i said
unlikely to happen but if it does
i think sony realizes that
especially with uh you know inflation
going on uh we're we're in the middle of
a recess a recession that stuff like
this could happen because microsoft's
got all this money
and they don't want to lose any of it so
yeah i i think
there's a lot of options when you have a
a multi-trillion dollar company that
doesn't want their
their
what's what i'm looking for their money
devaluing as much uh it's it's better to
invest that money than it sit in a bank
and lose and appreciate uh lose
appreciation over time and i don't think
people realize that people look at it
like all
why would why would square even excel
square
why activision sell call of duty makes a
lot of money every year overwatch makes
a lot of money every year wild makes a
lot of money every year sony microsoft
showed up
microsoft showed up there
and they're like
we got a bag for you like we got a big
big bag and guess what activision said
continue i'm interested exactly
very interesting they want to retire
that's all too
yeah man let me go and get these two
super chats we got a five dollar
sprinter from yo baby farva
sup fellas as an xbox player i operate
as if sony already owns square enix
we don't really get no love anyway so it
doesn't really faze me dirt
your baby farmer what's up homie and you
know thanks for stopping by we can we
can talk about the super chat for a
couple seconds
as an xbox player
he's he's not wrong they pretty much
they pretty much have already owned them
for a while sure yeah you get games like
probably the illusion yeah sure you get
games they publish but guess what
if score enix was owned by sony
they wouldn't be publishing these games
they'd still be a multiplayer like
it's just like people need to realize
that just because stuff like outriders
they're like oh addict outrighter still
comes to the play xbox uh octopath
traveler still comes to xbox
okay
your point your point
like it's just like these are published
games they're not made in-house for the
most part and if if mike if sony bought
square enix these published games would
go somewhere else because they can't go
to them anymore
just people people annoying me um
and that's not on uh you already be
farvo that's people on twitter uh five
dollars from alvin we tend to think of
acquisitions as just xbox and uh sony
but we do realize how much money square
in capcom made off nintendo they're not
giving that up
look i agree with you there's a lot of
money they can make off stuff like that
but it's like i said
you're looking as an individual
willing to sell because he's making more
money somewhere else i'm looking at says
board members that are corruptable that
would easily take a bag to sell their
stocks
i'm looking at this as a group of
individuals people act like you got to
convince all these these millions of
people to buy square enix most of the
time you gotta you you got to approve
you got to get the approval of maybe 100
people
sometimes more people don't realize look
there's a lot of stocks in every company
but most the time
a lot of the stocks are in a handful of
people the majority of stocks and
companies it's not like they're
everywhere like sure they're publicly
owned and a lot of people own stocks but
look what that happened with activision
and bobby why do you think he'd get in a
bag
why yeah
because he has a lot of stock in
activision and in order for that to
happen they had to buy his stock and
people sitting there oh don't give bobby
the bag don't you don't give him a
choice man don't give him a golden
parachute like what what do you expect
them to do at that point like just not
buy the company
right come on bro exactly man um so but
yeah but back to your virtual point um
playstation doing this it just makes all
the sense in the world
and i will say this back to my boy your
baby favorites point
as a xbox fan um as the xbox guy first
and foremost
i i'm not really losing anything because
i love the tomb raider franchise
that's
still going to be a multiplayer over
there with embracer
and and like they're west to their
western studios so for me personally
this guy is not really a final fantasy
fan
i i respect the franchise and i
appreciate what the franchise has done
and it's a huge franchise but for me
personally as an xbox fan
i'm not going to miss anything
personally now
i guess the difference would be
if like you know when zinni max was
acquired
a lot of playstation fans they're
missing out on some multi-platform games
but lately square enix games for the
most part they're big games
final fantasy games are exclusive to
playstation so i i wouldn't really miss
anything personally plus plus i have a
ps5 if i really wanted to play those
games so
yeah it's like i said man i'm not saying
that
they would never buy them or anything
like that
and i'm not saying that i want them to
buy them obviously at this point i will
say that even though that i'm a huge
you know i'm a huge
final fantasy fan well you know we'll
have to see what this new final fantasy
is
even though i love these franchises and
i love the games that they make at this
point
i have a playstation to play them
because i know
subconsciously that the best way to play
the games that i love to play is on
everything
at any point in any time
a game can be ripped away from you if
you only have one platform
absolutely and you have no choice but to
abide or shut the hell up
yeah absolutely and i feel like a lot of
people
they come at me they say addict you know
why are you complaining mega man battle
network isn't on xbox apparently um oh
tactic ogre that's not going to be on
xbox uh you know it might be but it's
it's highly looking like it's not going
to be why do i [ __ ]
because when that next one comes up
there i want i want phil to remember
something i want phil to sit there and
be like
yeah i got i better make sure like you
know let's say they they make a sequel
or they like rebrand it they're like
yeah
it's like adequate gonna be on my ass
[Laughter]
and it's not just me like if everyone
had that mentality it was an overall
thing like people don't realize the
power social media has the influence
social media has people act like the
only way to get something done is vote
for your wallet i would actually say
that an outcry
on
twitter is more effective
than voting with your wallet voting your
wallet happens after the fact most of
the time happens after the product came
out it happens after you know the
exchange of money has already happened
so if you don't give them your money
clearly they're going to see something
but i've never felt like that's a good
way of doing things i don't know how you
guys feel about it because there's too
many people that are ignorant to the to
the matter there's too many people that
don't keep up with stuff that they see
a star wars
battlefront 2 and the first thing they
see star wars they don't know the bad
practices that are going on there's way
more of them to outnumber us so i've
always felt like voting you for wallet
is is foolish you're never going to win
nothing's ever going to get changed you
know what changed battlefront 2
it was a twitter out cry and the reason
and you know it got to the point where
disney stepped in was like
yo more people gonna have to use this
license because clearly we can't trust
right
hey you know like another example xbox
live gold was that january of 2021
he was like hold on hold on even me you
know i'm a bot i made a video like hold
on man what the hell are y'all doing
y'all can't up up the price double the
prices just out of nowhere what nah man
so they they changed it that night but
there was a huge outcry like no xbox
what are y'all doing no
oh man so yeah but you're right about
that um
yeah even with playstation was it
horizon forbidden west at first
the upgrade fee was going to be 10 bucks
and then like like you know people said
hold on man you this is not what y'all
said y'all said free upgrade we want our
free upgrading play station
and then the damage control happened oh
it's only ten dollars i mean i got ten
dollars in my pocket and then uh
they strategically didn't put the ps4
version on the store on the playstation
you had to go to the website to get that
which i had to do because they hid it
from the console which is funny as ever
but you know people got a
damage control for everything it's like
the last of us remake and plus if xbox
ever successfully bought something like
um square enix
that would be devastating to sony like
we're not talking a little bit that
would be devastating like that's one of
those things where they have to have an
emergency meeting
and you know the back of mcdonald's and
they have to sit there on on their
little uh tables and they have to be
like okay are we willing to put game
pass on playstation like because
that's one of those things you know i i
felt like activision
was the now and if they bought square
enix that's the no in the coffin
yeah and
i honestly feel like i know you guys
probably won't agree
but i feel like if square e if if sony
ever agrees to put game pass on xbox i
mean on playstation
at that point
there's no more console for it
it's just like you can't you came in
there
with the bazooka it likes it it's just
like you're to listen to me and you're
going to abide to what i say i'm going
to shoot this straight in that building
yeah
if that ever happened uh yeah that's
that's pretty rough right there
but you know it is what it is i i i kind
of hope they bother them i'd like to see
uh the reaction on twitter you know on a
scale from one to ten bitcoin we'll go
around discover one to ten bitcoin
what's uh what's the reaction on twitter
you saying what how how much
entertainment you gonna have on twitter
on that day that they bought square enix
i mean it's
i'm going to be unaffected because it's
like again okay political thing okay
dirk griggity how scale from one to ten
how much entertainment you gonna have if
uh they buy scoring so you're gonna go
hide in the cave because i might hide in
the cave i don't know about you if
playstation bought square enix no no no
no no because it's it's expected and
like i said they're not taking anything
away from xbox now if if capcom if
somebody wants capcom
capcom it's a 10 i'm immediately
reacting that's the team bro i'm like
okay guys uh
about that resident evil looks like it's
only got one hand so they got one
yeah they came out and they gave us the
bungee thing we only bought them you
know they're not part of playstation we
bought them so they can help us with
stuff like that oh no that'd be nice
i would stay on twitter that day
yeah
for them know that that would go
immediately go back to that strategic
thing i was talking about with uh
esports and just pushing the competitive
aspect with teams that's the only thing
i would see if they actually did want to
do that but then buying them i don't
know i think
sounds more plausible plus
more beneficial because you'll see
dream projects that you guys know about
that you don't see no more like
dino crashes coming back like
some other stuff like you know it's a
lot of games
yeah yeah now that would be a reason
for like a guy like me or xbox gotta
hide capcom but screen it's nine
well
i'll make sure y'all won't get away if
that was the key i'll bring it up every
day all right
y'all playing that resident evil yeah
you know here's what y'all got to come
back though y'all be like oh you playing
that call of duty because you know i
don't think call of duty deals up it's
like it's looking shaky yeah the
playstation once once the deals are done
so
it is what it is you know we got a super
chat from uh
fallubia i probably butchered your name
we're gonna move past that man that's
your fault for me for naming yourself
something i can't pronounce that's all i
always say man when i can't pronounce
the super chat i blame it on the user
man they they knew i couldn't pronounce
that yeah somebody's named me crazy bro
they changed their name too
i don't normally go in on names because
a lot of people like you know um i can't
pronounce english terms half the time so
you know if we go out of the country you
definitely going to get an l on my part
like because i'm never going to be able
to pronounce it you're going to get a
laugh out of me butchering your name i
actually had someone that that said i
butchered their name so bad that they
had a double check to make sure their
name was that like
so he said what will be the point of
buying xbox then i assume are you saying
for xbox to buy square enix now look
there's actually a lot of reasons maybe
it's on my camera
oh for capcom i mean i mean
that's what i'm thinking look
xbox needs some type of
eastern influence in their first party
so that would be the reason xbox would
buy them and and sony would buy them
because they they're
you got stuff like tencent going around
uh you know microsoft is not the only
people out there with bank accounts that
that are are in the skies and i feel
like you got tents in google even google
you know google might slow down google
might have slowed down on stuff but we
don't know exactly what they're going to
uh in the future you know maybe they oh
stadium didn't work but they're like you
know what
steady didn't work but let's just go
ahead let's just make a console and
let's buy a bunch of platforms maybe
they learn stuff from the stadia failure
failure and they're able to
to capitalize
well
listen i know you're being nice
google saw what xbox spent for uh
zennymax
just zennimax not even at the video so
they were like oh if we got to spend 7.5
billion to be competitive in this
industry we out
it was like we have so you think they're
going to still do a council i don't
think so brother yeah we'll have to see
what to say i don't think they're doing
a cause i just said we don't we don't
know the things happen
and you know uh you know sony doesn't
know the future either so you know let's
go and talk about uh
about
halo forge
uh i don't know
uh
don't make me remove you from the stream
uh so we we got we got a little bit of a
leaks from halo forge now what's funny
is
there is actually ways on pc people are
are using programs to get around it
they're unhooking ethernet cords forge
is already in the game
it's just it's not it's d listed you
can't click on it like
there but what it is it does look like
you're able uh to trick your system
into not loading up correctly and it's
loading up forge
um
it's on pc i don't know if it's on xbox
and i do know that if you have the
preview build that you used to be able
to use to get on halo infinite back in
the day
before it was launched that one that has
the the building for that map on it um
it seems like some of those are having
forge on it it looks like maybe i think
microsoft might be using that build
to test out forge uh because they
de-listed it from the store keep in mind
so you have to have it downloaded you
cannot re-download it it's de-listed
so
first off how many people on the panel
have seen these crazy leaks
yeah i've seen some of them yep i've
seen some of them it looks cool man like
some of the ones i've seen look pretty
cool
is there anything in particular that you
saw
i remember seeing like a huge spartan in
the sky or something like that
uh you know i didn't see a lot of it
gonna kind of just scroll by it but
i'm one of them guys i don't i like to
wait for the final product to see some
of the things but i've been reading them
because i saw you said some very
interesting things about it you said
if like some of the things that you've
seen with ford if if this comes to a
fruition you say you're going to go back
you're going
be a halo if in the fanboy did you just
say it like that yeah
it's kind of crazy like hold up i'm
looking up uh
there was a video that i saw
that was absolutely oh my god
um
well i gotta put on my halo face happy
you're ridiculous
all right so here it is what i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna show you guys this let
me drop this link in here in the actual
chat so hold up
let me give you guys the the link so
there's the link
so we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
watch this
um this
this is insane like
seeing stuff like this gives me hope
that they actually
if they do what they're supposed to and
they they get stuff going i actually do
feel like you know they can do something
man they can do something now we don't
know
how well this is going to be someone get
that uh that uh chat up out of there i
don't know
uh you know
youtube needs to get on that because
that's good bro this stuff man
but it is
there we go
all right so here's what let me move
this over here all right so here's what
i'm talking about here all right let me
zoom it in
uh where you guys should be able to
still hear us
uh let me go ahead and transition it
all right now look at this look at this
okay so this is pretty much what's
happening here is i don't know if you
guys have it up but they're combining
weapons and forge uh shout out to let me
see who made this video let me who made
this video they were showing the pack a
punch machine as well yeah some dude
named orange made this video so shout
out to him all right so pretty much what
they're doing is they're combining
weapons so you're getting a sniper
obscure like they're they're if you see
up at the top
like you'll be able to see exactly what
it and if you listen
like
it's just crazy
like look i'm not saying that this is
enough reason to think that forge can
save halo but what i will say
is the possibilities is crazy
like you you look at here i saw someone
put a um
a pistol
with like a shotgun or something like
rocket launcher with the bulldog it's
crazy
and you know there is so many stuff on
here like it's
yeah the pop-ins pretty bad and i think
it's still in process like uh yeah the
reason you're seeing that is because i
do believe that they
the game's still in early like you know
it's not out yet but uh it is still
being worked on like you got someone
here
that built the um
the call of duty style barry uh barriers
where
they come in
yeah i'm gonna mute that because i'm not
gonna get hit before copyright claim but
it's just it's it's kind of crazy man uh
this dude has the
what someone here had the mystery box
from
from call of duty did you guys see that
yeah that's what i was doing about the
mystery books yeah
i didn't see that one it's literally a
mystery box from call of duty here it is
it's like the packaging has like the
packing punch machine and all that okay
yeah see pretty cool it's kind of crazy
now look obviously
it there are a little bit of things that
would be nice
you know we we need more
in diving when it comes to like how
something looks like i feel like it
would be cool if like the actual box
open maybe give people a little more
options to how something is presented
but i do feel like this is this is good
like i'm not gonna lie like this this
has potential this has potential
absolutely so you know i i just seen all
that like
do you guys think that
this could save halo uh you know we'll
start with
big cloud or do you think that a correct
forge done right and has good sharing
features has a lot of different
possibilities do you think it could save
halo
i mean it should have been there from
the start especially when they didn't
that wasn't the question
on the point but you know of course i
got asked uh
that's the thing uh
yes and no like it depends on what's
created and how popular they become and
how quick they are to react to them and
make them official maps and all that
stuff plus
um
you know
how many features they are giving the
creators in terms of forging so
it could
and it could not it could boost numbers
absolutely i can see people jumping on
for it but
the long-term process of this again it
comes down to
what we get so
yes and no wha what about you derek
what's your opinion
well i believe it will definitely
enhance it once it's you know
finished or out officially out because
i remember in halo 3 playing on some
maps man or some some some forest maps
just crazy crazy fun there's some a
bunch of crazy stuff going on
um so i believe it will enhance it um
but
i also feel that
three
their content
is really going to help the game out
more than even for us but like i said
ford's gonna be a lot of fun man like
especially when you see some of the
things people will create
some of the uh like you said the weapons
they combine the weapons and all this
other kind of stuff it's going to be fun
but i think it's just like
you know
i don't think halo
is dead on the xbox side maybe on the pc
side is a little lackluster right now
but
it's definitely going to help it
it's not going to hurt it
no we'll see man it might boost it for a
couple weeks you know oh so
right now nobody's talking about halo
that's the thing
yeah but you know
at the end of the day i think we need to
see we need to see more on what this can
actually do we need to see on what
people are going to do with it um i do
have a lot of hopes with that i'm not
going to say it's going to automatically
save the xbox brand
for people who who say there's no way
you weren't around for the for the halo
3's forge apparently
like you know halo 5's forge was pretty
lackluster
but halo 3 at that time
that it it it was crazy and all i'm
saying that if halo is able
if
the thing is 343 has good functional
abilities when it comes to sharing
content
i
don't think they're going to have like a
playlist where you click community
featured or anything like that maybe
they'll implement that later
uh but you know this is this is a good
thing this is a good start
i personally i'm with big cloud you know
at this moment
this is more important than than co-op
like by far because they need content
they don't need to be able to play with
other people
uh i do agree with that
uh but let's go ahead and uh move on to
this verizon park did you guys see
what's going on there
i didn't i know nothing about this i'm
just listening to you i don't know what
you're even like what's going on like
what's happening cloud
verizon partnership with whom apparently
with xbox
oh so apparently what they're gonna
start doing
is they're gonna start doing uh
the
what's that
the all-access program oh i did see this
yeah i did see
yeah they're gonna do the all-access
program
with verizon
uh so it's gonna be part of your bill
yeah i don't know if it's gonna be part
of your bill oh you know but it's
probably gonna be one of those things
because like when you walk into a
verizon
there's a lot of different
there's a lot of different options that
you have like you know they sell tablets
now they sell
you know watches like they they do a lot
more than just
your standard
um
just the phones like there's a lot more
options and stuff in there and i think
that you know this if this does well and
both
uh both people in the this relationship
benefit from it i wouldn't be surprised
if you start seeing this with at t and
with you know people don't realize
we got broke people everywhere man i'm
broke super chat if you guys want man
super chat you guys won't i'm broke
uh well actually it goes to the podcast
but but super chat
uh and you know a lot of people are they
have a lot more a functionability and
they have a lot more accessibility when
it comes to if they can go in there run
a credit score and walk out and just pay
something monthly uh that's the reason
you know people can't go out there and
spend
000 plus dollars on houses and cars and
stuff that's why they need you know uh
you know some kind of financial plane
yeah they need it because they can't do
that and i think we're going to see more
accessibility with consoles like what's
crazy is if they start doing well with
this
like imagine if you walk into your store
to get a phone and i thought oh why you
guys got an xbox here oh you know
imagine i
you gotta go walk in there oh you know
we could you go ahead and take we know
you just got approved for an iphone 12
uh you could take that home too for an
extra 30 40 bucks a month
like hey
they do that kind of stuff too at
verizon because i'm with verizon they i
got my daughter a phone like iphone 12
actually uh a couple weeks ago and they
said hey man uh
you're a phone you're right no i got
android i got a samsung galaxy
hey man yours is paid up
i will give you money off of your
daughter's phone if you upgrade to the
samsung galaxy 23 or 22 i was like man
come on
i didn't come here for a phone but
you're right that's what they do there
so just imagine hey uh so you're picking
up this iphone 13 that's great that's
great hey you know what xbox series s
hey you know
we're good like we'll give you 200 off
of your phone if you pick up an xbox
series that's on this xbox all access
that's the kind of stuff verizon does so
i can definitely see that in reality
yeah
like michael patrick's theory came true
only one it wasn't with like cable boxes
was with this
we'll see i think cable's so out the
door i don't you might see it still with
the boxes i remember but see i do feel
like that kind of logic made sense at
the time like i wouldn't blame someone
that would think something but not for
the guys
not for the price he was saying i think
he was like 100 like well unless they
were able to do it but like a hundred
dollars for a console
and that would be like your cable box
type of thing and you paid your bill
through them or something there's a lot
of stuff there's on there
it's kind of crazy how things work if
you want if you want to be honest like
look like i'm not going to say
that all this stuff is 100 people don't
know how some of this stuff works and
that's just how it goes um we don't know
exactly what kind of back end you know
it i don't know
because to me why would verizon do it if
there's still a fixed-in rate and they
don't raise the price
you know what i'm saying like what does
verizon get out of that
because most of the time for those who
don't know how the cell phone industry
works is they buy
in bulk from the manufacturers for a
lower point uh place point then they do
you know uh you they lease you your
phone they finance your phone that's how
they make money
yeah and to me if they can't finance
these consoles because the the prices
look identical to what sony microsoft's
doing i just don't know what they're
gonna get
you know maybe that's a good question
maybe there's something else on the back
end maybe microsoft's writing them a
check that says no questions asked i
don't know we'll have to see more on
that man more on that i feel like we're
going to come back to this and i feel
like it's either going to be
well you what do they expect it's a sony
it's it's a it's a cell phone provider
you know there's nothing there's nothing
to do with that why would
people going in to to upgrade their
phones by an xbox so or we come back
with the conversation yo that was
ingenious
that was crazy and you know
it's just like look like
the more obvious
i i decided i didn't want the smoke
so what you guys said no i'm good so
it just it just depends on what they do
how they interact with it i'm very
curious we'll come back to this in a
couple months uh you know i i'm gonna go
to the horizon maybe ask some questions
man all right so let's
let's talk about the bread and butter
the meat and potatoes oh
couture has been delayed for those of
you that don't know what couture is it's
star wars nice the old republic uh it
has been delayed
indefinitely
yo yo they get they hit them with the
day uh with the die uh
the um what's that game called dead not
dead island well that's right that's
pretty much canceled um what's the other
zombie dying light two remember when
dying light two got hit with the
indefinitely delayed yeah it wasn't
definitely delayed for like a year and a
half
uh so
it's been rumored i think it was jason
schreier wasn't it
uh yep yeah so it's been indefinitely
delayed that's that's uh
that's one of sony's big things that i
actually gave them a lot of props for
taking those props back
uh you know maybe there's there's a
reason that microsoft didn't work with
this company maybe yeah maybe they saw
that build it was like we ain't doing
that yeah let me just let me see your
builds they saw that
they saw that it was like good
yeah it's like yeah you take that to
sony they they like that stuff they like
our leftovers our our our stuff we had
10 15 years ago you know they oh man
they like that stuff
yeah that's like there we go
no i would prefer them to have it that's
all jokes uh you know but it's just like
you know i want some you know feedback
from uh you know we'll go with big cloud
first because it's a little bit more
playstation centric like when you first
heard this
what did you think of this
this thing and apparently
it was okay
and then they showed a early testing a
build a gameplay and then after that
they fired one of the main people and
then it got indefinitely delayed yeah i
fired both of the the directors for it
and whatnot so yeah um dev secret told
me uh when he was in the discord because
i didn't see it on twitter yeah he told
me i wasn't going no no way then he said
the full league and i was like
why you mean him had this long
conversation about like why that was one
of the games i was looking forward to so
now we're on the release date but what i
think is my theory is uh lucasfilms
also saw this built on top of sony and
whatnot and
there's like listen
this saying that because you know
lucasfilm is trying to while they
i would say they have the final say but
you know they're heavily involved with
it like yeah they like to they like to
make stuff canon and they write books
and novels based off of stuff to include
them in the universe so
when you look at this and you're like
jedi's survivor
which is going to be
it's like great that's again it's like
wow you know like
i didn't think
we would get to this type of situation
though we still got games to look
forward to but it's like
damn like i kind of would have loved the
leak sneak peek of this build do they
leak the last of us can we can we can we
link this like i don't want to see what
they were
seeing
uh in terms of this uh built but
it sucks man i i was looking forward to
it um now it doesn't mean like we
probably won't get no info next year
yeah they did say indefinitely but again
that doesn't mean that you probably
won't ever hear from it again you'll you
probably will hear something
involved in this game next year and
you'll you'll get something but not
it still sucks because it's like
you know
star wars is like absolutely killing it
right now they're on a great stride the
kenobi show did really really well you
had knight to the republican remake got
jedi survivor then you have uh quantic
dreams making their star wars game and
then you have
uh mandalorian on the side so you have
tons of content for star wars like star
wars is that big right now and it's one
of my favorite things of all time like
blake
i was looking forward to just seeing
this and seeing more but
i am willing to wait but because you
know we have jedi survivor which is
probably next year yeah so so
we we're we're fine for now but it does
make you question like damn what's
what's really happening and also you
know what else in terms of future
projects like are we going to get a
mandalorian game and all that stuff
because they're really having fun with
the license which is what i wanted to
see now that ea doesn't have a monopoly
on it anymore after the the garbage that
was the battlefront uh situation so yeah
but that's where i'm at with it
yeah i feel like when it comes to this
you're gonna there's there's two
different possibilities there's probably
multiple but this too i could see
um you're going to either a it's going
to take a while but you're going to see
the studio
come back from the ashes of the phoenix
and either make a good game or a shitty
game uh i probably wouldn't expect any
kind of info from this until like late
next year early the year after
uh yeah and that might even be a stretch
depending on how bad uh the the the bill
that they showed these uh executives was
because if it was really really bad then
yeah it's gonna be a couple yeah then
then version two happens you know what
version two is they're going final
fantasy vii that that that ass they they
they gonna rip it from from the
developer and give it to someone else
uh and then also if they do that that
will end up changing contracts that will
end up changing like in order for them
to do that because most likely that
developer is in that contract for that
game they might have to avoid the whole
damn thing
uh and who knows the game might even get
canceled in general depending on how bad
that studio situation is yeah uh and it
looked like it was bad to say
indefinitely that means the the room's
on fire and they looking for water and
they don't have enough time
to update stuff because to me they just
showed us that game not long ago
but not too far ago i felt like they
didn't need to show us this information
right now they could have went another
six months to a year before people
started asking where corporal was
uh i felt like they said that early
because they know
they're not going to have anything for
us in the long term so i do feel like
there's a good chance this either gets
cancelled
or
uh they they switch developers now i
don't know you know they might
precaution yeah i don't know they might
stay with the developer they have now
but they might just hire a little bit
more from within uh but nine times out
of ten when something like this happens
and someone doesn't like uh you know the
preview build that bad something
drastically changes i just don't know
what it's going to be yet
what's your feeling dirt man because i
know when we saw that couture it burned
a little bit it was burning a little bit
and now
i want to the fanboy in me
is like
well good now i don't have to hear any
playstation fanboy talk about this game
for a while but then like the knights of
the old republic fan in me it's like
right
damn i can't get to play no time soon
oh man this is just uh more proof that
not every
studio
is is you know
without their issues um
i just think that when they first
announced the game i was like who who's
developing this i never heard of them i
don't know if you guys have i've never
heard of them
um
that's why i was like i'm gonna have to
see like yeah it's just like none of the
big people are developing and i'm not
saying this this team can't do big
things but nine times out of ten a
smaller studio can't really
give you the type of product like you
want like we want from this kind of game
right and from a remake from this kind
of game because they don't have the
manpower uh and i don't know what kind
of how many people's over there maybe a
big cloud you can look that up if you
have time i see how many people work for
that company but uh sorry uh dart you
finished what you're saying no so i
looked them up and i saw they um kind of
helped with stuff the zombie um back in
the ps2 xbox generation
um they ported some star wars games uh
they had ios sport of um
star wars night at old republic
what's that in the old coach
yeah some other stuff you know say they
even know they did some ports but like
they really they haven't done many
original games and obviously this isn't
an original game this is just a remake
um so
that was the first red flag for me i
just you know i look like man what what
has this team done
um so that's something that we should
always look at in the future so i mean
like we obviously don't know what
happened we're not behind closed doors
but
when you see uh big directors being
fired
that's definitely a red flag i remember
when some people left three four three
and you know some of us xbox guys like
you always all good it's all good my man
no that's something we should really
look at when people at the top
of a development team
leaves or or gets fired that's something
to really think about man uh so yeah
the writer behind gta 5 or the dan
hauser he's now with the project yeah
man
so
it's a lot of stuff
yeah
in the future i don't care if it's xbox
playstation any studio naughty dog 343
coalition when people are at the top
leaves or there's some type of issues we
should really look at that like
there's potential issues there we
shouldn't you know there's nothing
you know not it's different if you know
if a lower level person leaves i mean
one person leave here one person leave
there but if two are being fired
simultaneously
like what
what the hell is going on man so yeah um
as far as the game
itself can it be canceled i think it's a
big time possibility man because they're
saying uh
and definitely that means
that means something to me and
definitely
we won't have a clue
we don't have a clue if they're even
developing the game right now they're
probably restructuring who's going to be
the lead man this game might not be out
if it doesn't get canceled till about 20
25 like you guys said
yeah
it's just it's sad man it's sad because
uh i do have a huge interest in this in
this game
i've always really enjoyed uh knights of
the old republic i remember playing the
first and second one uh you know i'm
gonna ask you both to like who would you
prefer this game to go to i'm going to
say mine first like somebody hit up
microsoft this game got to go to
obsidian man like obsidian obsidian
needs to make this i don't care if it's
still a multi-plat
damn it could be for playstation only
let let microsoft's first party work on
an exclusive game for playstation i
don't care i just want the best knights
of the old republic
that's there and i'm not saying the
studio can't do it we'll have to see
need more information uh people say blue
point um
blue point could do it but here's the
thing that's why it's good with the
aesthetic has blue point made a
an rpg like that like
nah but like again i can see them
bringing and being able to bring it
into this type of era in in a crazy way
you know what they deal with demon souls
i mean that's chef chef's kiss uh while
they die yeah that was really good and
then someone said coalition needs to
make a tur rock i actually would like
turok uh i guess uh t-u-r okay i
actually would like uh i would like
coalition to either make a punisher game
or an army of two game
i'm saying like yeah because they
already missed an opportunity with
microsoft with black panther black
panthers getting made by e8 from a
correct light team but yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and um again after seeing that i saw the
black panther trailer and i'm like dude
yeah it's i got high hopes for him at
the same time i'm worried you know
but
why not daredevil you know there's so
many characters they can be going after
but at this rate sony's probably gonna
have their own mcu
yeah i agree with you and it's sad it's
just like look like
you know
right now it's fine i don't think like
people think that
microsoft needs to like copy their
third-party action adventure call gloves
is a hashtag one i do think one's fine
you know give a couple of those type of
experiences but i don't think that
you know you can't fight sony at what
they do best you just can't like you can
i would say you take a studio or two
you work up that studio to be your
naughty dog in five ten years uh but you
don't try to take them on at their best
you know
i honestly personally think that
diversity is going to be microsoft's key
to
having a better lineup than sony uh you
know sony's still gonna have the huge
hitters like god of war ragnarok last of
us part three four five six seven uh you
know uh
if they make another uncharted uh but
you know if if we get stuff like that
but you start seeing more rpgs coming
out of microsoft k and they have to be
high quality they don't have to be 90
plus but they have to at least be above
80 at that point you
some can slip but most of them got to be
decent quality and it's just like you
know you start seeing more rpgs fallouts
uh elder scroll type games then you
start seeing more racers you know i
guess you don't have to really do
anything with the racing genre because
they got two developers making racers
then you start these strategy games you
start seeing stuff like hellblade uh you
start seeing a lot more rts going to pc
and xbox you start seeing a lot more of
a migration between them you're seeing
this discord thing happening right now
where we can actually communicate with
people see what they're doing with
minecraft like that's the way microsoft
truly takes off and i do feel like
they're going to get there one day it's
just between how they handle the xbox
one generation how they almost got gave
up on the brand itself and there was a
good amount of time during that
generation that they wasn't really
investing too much and by the time they
took it serious when they started
getting stuff out there like look man
we're gonna have this stuff out in 2022
on the pandemic happen and then that
slowed everything six months to a year
uh so you're seeing a lot of that and
like i'm not giving them excuses like
people want to sit there and say that
you can't use the pandemic as an excuse
because everyone else is doing it when
everyone else isn't doing it the only
difference is
sony had a lot of games that was midway
through development that that at that
time
they could pivot a little bit more
because they wasn't
hardcore into into massive production uh
you know it is what it is and i do think
microsoft's size in general has hurt
them with the pandemic because uh anyone
that runs a big company knows the bigger
you are something like the pandemic's
gonna cr
is to interrupt your flow way more than
a smaller company and i think probably
during the pandemic microsoft sure they
were concerned about xbox but they were
probably more concerned about the cloud
con
structuring companies that make them
billions they're i'm sure xbox was still
given enough resources to fix stuff but
you got to understand when the pandemic
happened sony only really had to worry
about a couple things
you know obviously there's a lot of
moving targets but microsoft had
multiple billion dollar companies to
worry about during that time frame and i
think a lot of stuff fell into the
cracks uh so i do think that that helped
sony a little bit sure i would say
microsoft probably was a little bit more
better up to do
uh you know remote uh remote work they
probably have a lot more infrastructures
in place
but you have more
resources to to do that stuff for sure
yeah but now we're seeing that you know
i wouldn't say the pandemics through
people act like it's through it's not
we're still in a pandemic but i will say
that we're coming on the tail end of it
hopefully things will start going back
to normal in the next like a year and a
half to two and hopefully we'll start
seeing these games come out because i do
feel like microsoft
needs to show stuff um like that's why i
was so happy with the forge because it's
like i'm tired of hearing about who's
being hired
who's this who's that i don't care at
this point you show me results or you
stay your ass off twitter that's my mind
it's like don't come out there and show
me we hired some person that worked at
microsoft 30 years ago i don't care
show me a game or keep your ass off
twitter i'm not saying like don't tweet
i'm saying don't give me updates on a
brand that you have done nothing but
show negative stuff on i only want to
see
results i don't want to see any more
talking and that's just how i go through
you know what do you feel dirt man how
do you feel like you know knights of the
old republic getting delayed do you
think that
might agree disagree or agree on stuff
like what is your overall perspective on
this
on this game
well i think it's like any other game
being delayed indefinitely um
whether you're a fan or not it's a game
being delayed that's a game that was
on sony's roadmap that's been delayed
that you know nobody knows when it's
going to be
even start being developed developed
again um so i'm sure some playstation
fans is upset about that like guys like
yourself you know you were looking
forward to coach or so yeah you're upset
about that um
but i guess that's just how it goes
there's not
they aren't the only team that has had
issues they aren't the only team
that's been affected by the pandemic
like you said i remember in 2020 a lot
of people were saying
you're gonna see
the uh what like what's the word uh i'll
be forgetting words now bro if i'm
getting old or whatever
the after effects of the pandemic um
yeah we haven't like 20 22.
yeah but
we're starting to see like certain
things like 20 2022 2023 we're gonna
start seeing it not in the gaming
industry i mean we're gonna see more and
more games being delayed and you know
we've seen games being delayed right now
of course but this year
not just on xbox side you know like
playstation has been able to have so
have some games you know coming out this
year but those games were delayed from
last year but there's a game that we
play on my podcast called yes the
metacritic right we haven't done that
game in weeks
because there hasn't been any no big
games coming out there's been some games
of course
but no triple a big first party games
has really been out since what
gt7 maybe um
yeah i mean i'm so and here we go we
won't have any until maybe saints row
and then god of war and call of duty you
know the holiday season
so um i think hopes for being being i'm
sorry not counsel being uh indefinitely
um on hold
i think it's gonna affect um you know
those people that want to play the game
and
you know i guess sony's roadmap i would
like to see what big cloud think about
it i know he mentioned some things
earlier because i got into it with some
playstation guys yesterday about roadmap
you know because that's the only thing
that's xbox guys can really
talk about right now roma our roadmap
looks great
which is something we didn't have last
generation so that's something you know
we can talk about now so
yeah man i guess it's just
it is what it is my brother
all right so so what's any last words
for you bitclad because i know you was
actually wanting to play this game too
yeah
i don't know what to say at this point i
mean it's like
i guess we'll just wait
let's put it blood we'll just wait
that's
there's so much
that's all you can do man that's how we
can do it right that's all you could do
at this point uh so many things
contributing uh right now uh we
you know even though all this stuff's
happening i am grateful at least that we
got a lot of good releases this year we
still got something to look forward to
ties over december's looking lit we got
kalista protocol for there
um
yeah that looks good yeah if you guys
want that last of us uh remastered it's
in september
you
see but we have had some like smaller
games though
yeah for sure
and so i mean you know microsoft's
future looks good it's just you know
gotta wait nothing and once the game's
dropped they dropped
that's it
yeah hey you know
like i always say you know yes we've
been waiting
but this waiting is a little bit
different as opposed to something like
2018 2017. because that was
waiting like bro we was waiting
we didn't know what was coming currently
right now i will agree with you because
that back then we was just waiting for
hope for
i for for anything man like you you
that's why xbox guys always said way to
e3 because we was hoping it was going to
show some e3 the upcoming e3 and it
really didn't happen but
this waiting is
this is a little different you know
you're not you you know some of the
things that's coming so
you know it's a it's a you know it's
much better
it's it's sad man it's sad but uh you
know pretty much we're we're gonna go
ahead and uh we're gonna go ahead and
end this so you know dirt what's what's
going on with you man what do you got
going on
nothing much man you know i had to rush
home
uh to get to the show today i was i was
not that late like wasn't that that no i
was only a couple minutes late right
yeah yeah what's funny is um
uh you use here sooner than big cloud
but you know that's that's not my
business
uh what what show you guys got going on
man
uh you know we um
you know check out the latest episode of
uh
wbgsbox podcast you know we had a good
show he's talking trash as usual
um stop by check it out we had uh you
know like one of my um my panel members
got just this alternate character named
cocaine r b he just i don't know what's
wrong with him man he's it's alter ego
he just shows up once in a while screams
and leaves so i don't know something
like some people might not like him but
some people do like him so yeah stop by
check out the last show man it's funny
stuff
so big cloud man what's going on with
you what you got popping over there man
you got a lot of stuff going on what you
got going on
now how are we chilling man just
chilling uh
sorry for me being late again tying that
on successfully that was that was cool
uh
everybody in the chat hit that like
button if you haven't done so you guys
want to follow me it's big cloud gaming
i covered everything uh that's been
happening this week's on the channel
drop some videos you guys want to check
those out they're there
um also rgt podcasts every friday 5 p.m
eastern standard time for now until
september then we're gonna go to seven
so um that's what's going on there as
well
and uh yeah later on today solid gas
nine o'clock
go over the whole uh situation involving
gta i also did a video on that as well
all right so uh what you know i
appreciate if we're coming through like
i said we're gonna have a lot of stuff
changing here in the next
probably um i would say
three or four months i got gotta have
some stuff uh
worked on uh also you know what what i
plan on doing eventually is having
having like an iop and addict show uh
collab i don't know when that's gonna be
uh because uh you know i i want to do
more stuff with the community too that's
why i'm saying i might switch my
my gaming addict channel into a
streaming chat i don't know i
i don't know if if streaming on youtube
is the vital thing like i get it some
people are having pretty good success
with it
but it's just like i don't think i would
have success with it now let me make
sure i didn't miss
super you gotta you just got one from uh
thai
i have a two dollar super uh super chat
damn i missed the show from ty uh ty
kinesis chris
caceres casares and then
tycho seriously 15 super chat from the
same person
kyson uh canaris
caisson aries i apologize have you any
of you tried the halo 2
challenge for 20k do ain't no way ain't
no way i'm doing that stuff like look at
that 20k sounds nice and what's funny is
i was seeing people that was like
i did this when i was a kid the [ __ ] yo
ass up and go do it like
you gotta advertise it yeah that's what
i'm saying like if anything you should
keep your mouth shut go straight to that
xbox like
make that money oh no we don't want to
do that i don't have time i gotta work
yeah sure you do and
i'm still trying to figure out this
redirect thing like youtube needs to get
on this [ __ ] dude like it just
it's just
you say my name from now on no i'm not
saying i don't know i i don't know maybe
i said it though the way you liked it a
little too much i don't know man we're
gonna we ain't gonna talk about that man
but you know i appreciate everyone
coming through appreciate all the
support uh i am going to to mess around
a little bit on like some of the
features that uh obs has i just want the
podcast to pop a little bit if that
makes sense
uh you know we'll figure it out uh you
know it's like i said i will be back
next week hopefully there will be
something to you know you know what i
will say real quick because i was really
happy there was stuff to talk about this
week you guys have no idea how bad it's
been to run a podcast i don't want to
talk about the last of us again
oh you know the size of this
um last year we're gonna talk about
chevy dollars
oh seventy dollars yeah i ain't talking
about that i thought you were gonna spin
it's like hey is seventy dollars good
for you i'm like uh this guy nah
yeah
i think you're gonna do it you know i
get that but you there is a question i
do have for you big cloud is 70 dollars
really good for the industry
oh boy no we ain't talking about that
but i appreciate you guys for coming out
we're gonna go and end the show and
until next time this is dirk griggity
big clown and addict and we will see you
next week on the attic show